il clignote ils roulent ils parlent
les jeux électroniques sont source de
réjouissance et de crainte
depuis qu'ils ont débarqué dans nos
foyers dans les années 70
l'émerveillement de la technologie de la
gadgétisation et de l'électronique
reléguée aujourd'hui au second plan les
poupées de chiffons les jouets en bois
ou en peluche et la pâte à modeler ils
deviennent incontournables dans les
années 80 tout un champ s'ouvre à
l'enfant avec ses technologies
mais très vite les commentaires à propos
de ces jouets font place au premier
bémol
personne ne sait non plus si les enfants
s'intéressent ont longtemps à ce type de
jouet qui coûte cher et qui laisse bien
peu de place à l'imagination
les parents cèdent aux envies
d'électronique de leurs enfants mais ils
s'interrogent ces jouets sont ils des
fabriques à crétins la question se pose
depuis les débuts et en particulier en
2000 quand l'électronique a gagné les
jouets destinés aux plus jeune âge on y
descend sur stimulée par les jouets par
leurs parents parce qu'on avait
découvert compétent et que maintenant on
leur fournit des jouets très
sophistiquée et qu'en même temps une
plus le temps de créer de là à bannir
ces jouets pas forcément en 2010 la
règle selon les pédiatres
c'est plutôt la modération trop de
technologie va retirer un peu la la la
la possibilité de développer leur
imaginaire et donc l'enfant après sera
toujours en demande de ces jeux
électroniques sans oublier que parmi ces
jouets électroniques
certains sont à visée éducative ou
stratégiques qui permettent de
développer le langage où l'esprit
tactique de
[Musique]